stormy webster is officially on big
sister duty because kylie jenner and
travis scott just welcomed baby number
two i'm excited about it the 24 year old
reality star shared this black and white
snap on instagram sunday that's stormy
holding her newborn sibling's tiny hand
the caption the baby's b-day 2-22
alongside a blue heart emoji a rep for
kylie confirms to e.t it's a boy thank
you
so then the kardashian jenners did what
the kardashian jenners do you know
spread love in the comments kylie's
oldest sister courtney writing mommy of
two life kim and chloe chiming in with
blue heart emojis it's exciting as for
their momager kris jenner she wrote
simply angel pie oh my gosh such a gift
before reposting the pick to her own
account with the caption my beautiful
grandson
makes me proud the baby boy whose name
has yet to be revealed came four years
and one day after his big sister who
turned four on february 1st kylie marked
this special day posting this black and
white pic to instagram that's the makeup
mogul with travis and their little girl
embracing alongside the caption quote
our baby is four happy birthday to the
girl that changed my whole world i'm
having so much fun back in september
kylie confirmed the happy news that they
were expecting posting this sweet video
of the couple's positive pregnancy test
their visit to the doctor's office and
the sweet moment the entrepreneur broke
the news to her mom what do you have for
lovie
oh what is this
this is one of the happiest days of my
life
at the time kylie's famous fam swooped
into the comments to share their
excitement kim writing quote crying i'm
so excited about it and courtney she
echoed all that quote crying this is so
beautiful my blessed angel sister
beautiful
amazing last month kylie celebrated her
second child with friends and family at
a lavish baby shower and shared pics on
instagram including a gorgeous
tablescape complete with personalized
blankets lots of stunning flowers and a
giraffe motif i love it and while
kylie's relationship with the 30 year
old rapper has been on and off over the
years a source told e.t in august that
the two were quote in a great place
adding that having another child was
always a part of their plan quote kylie
absolutely loves being a mom and is so
excited to be a new mom again i'm
obsessed with it and ahead of the new
year kylie shared a snap of her bear
baby bump alongside a caption that read
in part quote i will never forget this
year and all the significant changes it
made to my life i pray this new year is
filled with a lot of love
[Music]